you know what does it mean to live an
ethical life I asked them to think about
the impact that they can have about the
consequences of their actions uh what
they can do to make the world a better
place than it would have been if they
hadn't lived in it there are all sorts
of choices that you have to make about
how you're going to live so for me to
live an ethical life it's not enough
just to say I'm going to obey some
simple moral rules like don't still
steal don't cheat don't don't hurt other
people
um you have to think also about what can
I do positively given the advantages
that I have and the problems that we
have in the world